DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
AFTER THE FALSE INCOMING MISSILE
ALERT IN HAWAII, LODGE
NOTIFICATIONS WILL REQUIRE
VERIFICATION BY TWO PEOPLE.
YOU THINK THAT WOULD'VE BEEN IN
PLACE ALREADY.
MAY BE A WARNING THAT PROMPTS
YOU TO DOUBLE-CHECK THE MESSAGE
BEFORE IT GOES OUT.
WHEN I WANT TO DELETE AN EMAIL,
I AM ASKED, ARE YOU SURE YOU
WANT TO DELETE AN EMAIL.
THAT'S FOR AN EMAIL, NOT A STATE
ALERT TELLING PEOPLE THEY ARE
ONE THAT SAYS "JUST TESTING."
THAT'S LIKE HAVING THE KIDS
TRAMPOLINE NEXT TO A WOOD
ALL GOING TO DIE AND FOR
40 MINUTES, THAT'S YOUR REALITY.
THEN SOMEONE COMES ALONG AND
SAYS OOPS.
MY WIFE WAS IN HAWAII.
WOULD NEVER SEE THEIR KIDS
AGAIN.
SHE WATCHED FAMILIES SAYING
WHAT A CONTRAST BETWEEN REAL
TERROR AND PHONY POSTURING.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO REPORT THIS
MISSILE ACTED WITH SUCH
RESTRAINT DAYS AGO WERE MELTING
OVER S-HOLE.
WHEN THE PRESS CONFERENCE WENT
IN HAWAII, WE TOOK ALIVE.
CNN RAN A REPEAT INTERVIEW WITH
MICHAEL WOLFF.
MAYBE IF THAT FALLS MISSILE
IT'S DISGUSTING THAT AN EVENT
INTERESTING TO THE PRESS THAN A
CRUDE PHRASE IN A MEETING.
HE'S NOT TAKING THIS SERIOUSLY
AND THERE'S NO THREAT TO
NUCLEAR THREAT FROM KOREA.
HER STATES WARNING SYSTEM
SCREWED UP AN OPTIONAL PASS TO
MAKE HIS GEOPOLITICAL
CALCULATIONS BASED ON THAT?
NO, HOW ABOUT SETTING A SYSTEM
THAT DOESN'T TERRIFY PEOPLE FOR
38 MINUTES AND THEN YOU CAN TAKE
PART IN THE CONVERSATION.
UNTIL THEN, FIX YOUR OWN
BACKYARD.
THIS INFURIATES ME.
IF THIS HAD HAPPENED, DANA,
NEW YORK CITY, THE MEDIA WOULD
CARE.
INSTEAD THEY'VE ALREADY MOVED ON
ABOUT THE MOST RIDICULOUS
THINGS.
>> Dana: ANYTHING THAT HAPPENS
IN NEW YORK GETS OVER COVERED.
WE KNOW THAT.
SOMETIMES IT'S WARRANTED.
YOU WOULD THINK PEOPLE WOULD
LIKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO
HAWAII TO COVER A STORY.
THE HOLES IN THE SYSTEM.
SO THAT'S GOOD.
AND I ALSO THINK THAT IT SHOWED
HOLES IN OUR OWN FAMILY
PLANNING.
RIGHT AFTER 9/11, THERE'S A BIG
PUSH, CALLED READY.GOV, PART OF
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
THERE IS A ADVERTISING PUSHED OR
TALKED ABOUT FAMILIES ABOUT
HAVING A PLAN.
THAT IF SOMETHING HAPPENS, THIS
SOME SORT OF PROTECTION, NO
FOOD, WATER.
WE'VE GOTTEN AWAY FROM THAT.
THIS WAS A BIG WAKE-UP CALL FOR
WAKE-UP CALL.
BUT THEY'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM OF HAWAII.
>> Jesse: THEY HAVE TO FIRE
SCREWUP.
THEY SCREWED UP SO INSTEAD OF
SAYING FALSE ALARM, THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING READY TO GO IN THE
SCRIPT.
THEY TOOK 38 MINUTES TO COME UP
WITH THIS.
ARE YOU READY?
THERE IS NO MISSILE THREAT OR
DANGER TO HAWAII.
TO COOK UP THAT TWEET.
AND THEY DON'T FIRE ANYBODY.
THEY REASSIGN THEM.
WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO CAUSE MASS
HYSTERIA?
THE GUY GETS REASSIGNED.
THE PARTY THAT WANTS BIGGER
GOVERNMENT IS OKAY WITH THIS.
THEY SCREW UP SO BIG IN THE
STATE OF HAWAII.
DON'T TAKE ANY RESPONSIBILITY
WANT TO GIVE GOVERNMENT MORE
HEALTH CARE, MORE POWER OVER
YOUR LIFE, MORE POWER OVER YOUR
BUSINESS.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE DON'T
HAVE BIG, BLOATED GOVERNMENT.
KIMBERLY, THEY CLAIMED THEY WERE
ACCORDING TO JOHN ROBERTS, FEMA
DIDN'T NEED AUTHORIZATION.
THEY KNEW 5 MINUTES THIS WASN'T
REAL.
TO MAKE SURE, WHAT CAN WE DO TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T LOOK LIKE
HAWAII AND HAVE A MAJOR PROBLEM.
THIS IS REALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
I DON'T LIKE WHEN SOMEBODY
GETS -- WILL JUST REASSIGN YOU.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE OF
NATIONAL SECURITY.
PEOPLE WERE IN CHAOS AND PANIC.
THERE.
>> Kimberly: THEY WOULD'VE HAD
DISASTER MOVIE THAT PEOPLE SLAP.
WAKE-UP!
WORST PART OF ME.
>> Jesse: I AM SURE SHE HAS
SEEN IT ALREADY.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
JUAN, I FEEL TULSI GABBARD MADE
THE LEAP TO NORTH KOREA A VERY
POLITICAL LEAP.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
NORTH KOREA.
YOU DON'T JUMP AND BLAME TRUMP
FOR HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
NORTH KOREA.
ABSURD.
THAT'S WHERE THE THREAT COMES
FROM.
>> Greg: THE THREAT WAS THERE
INCOMPETENCE.
>> Juan: THE THREAT IS THAT
NORTH KOREA'S 4500 MILES FROM
HAWAII.
SO EVERYBODY WANTS TO DEAL WITH
THE SOURCE OF THE THREAT.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT IF THIS WAS
BADLY MANAGED, AND I AGREE WITH
JESSE 100%.
IF YOU KNEW IN 5 MINUTES IT WAS
THE PUBLIC.
YOU LIKE ANYTHING TO DEFEND
TRUMP.
>> Greg: THIS IS HUGE.
>> Juan: WHAT YOU SEE IS THAT
TRUMP DIDN'T TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
SO YOU SHOULD BE SCREAMING AT
TRUMP.
PEOPLE YOU LOATHE, JAMIE LEE
CURTIS, MONTEL WILLIAMS, ALL
THOSE PEOPLE ARE SAYING
CRICKETS.
NOTHING FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Greg: YOU WANT THEM TO
RESPOND EMOTIONALLY?
>> Juan: I THINK HE SHOULD
>> Greg: LET'S DO THAT.
I THINK WE HAVE SOUND ON TAPE OF
DONALD TRUMP RESPONDING.
>> THAT WAS A STATE THING, BUT
WE ARE NOW GOING TO GET INVOLVED
WITH THEM.
I LOVE THAT THEY TOOK
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY TOOK TOTAL RESPONSIBILITY
BUT WE ARE GOING TO GET
INVOLVED.
TAKE TOTAL RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY MADE A MISTAKE.
>> Juan: YOU CAN SEE THIS
CONCERN IS "DON'T BLAME ME.
WASN'T ME THIS TIME."
OUTRAGE.
>> Greg: THE PROPORTION IS SO
CYBER TERROR CAN COME IN LOTS OF
DIFFERENT FORMS.
PROBABLY COULDN'T CONCEIVE OF
THOSE FORMS.
GOVERNMENT, TRYING TO BE MORE
CREATIVE THAN WHAT A CRIMINAL OR
LEADS TO AN ACCIDENT, WHETHER IT
BE BECAUSE PEOPLE CRASH INTO
EACH OTHER ON THE HIGHWAY TRYING
TO GET OUT OR SOMETHING MUCH
WORSE.
INCLUDING RETALIATION.
YOU COULD LOSE A LOT OF LIVES
FOR NOTHING.
>> Greg: JUAN BROUGHT UP SOME
OF THE SINGLE-DIGIT I.Q.
CELEBRITIES LIKE JAMIE LEE
CURTIS AND THE ODIOUS JIM CARREY
LET ME QUOTE JIM CARREY.
WHAT IS HE DO?
REAL PSYCHIC WARNING.
HE'S REALLY DEEP LIKE THAT.
HE UNDERSTANDS PSYCHIC WARNINGS.
WE ALLOW THIS ONE-MAN GOMORRAH
BEYOND ALL IMAGINATION.
HERE YOU HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
FAILED ITS PEOPLE AND HE GOES
AFTER TRUMP.
THERE IS NO CAUSAL OR LOGICAL
CONNECTION TO THE EVENT AND
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME?
I SEE.
WE HAVE A FLINTSTONE VITAMINS
FOR YOU, GREG.
AT ONE POINT ARE YOU GOING TO
BEING NOT SURPRISED AND
NONPLUSSED BY THIS.
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY THIS IS WHAT
THEY DO AND IF THERE'S ANY WAY
TO TRY TO CONNECT IT.
FOR IT AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK
COOPERATIVELY.
HE TRIED TO BUTTON IT UP.
NEVERTHELESS, THIS IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FALL SO THEY
WANT TO MISCHARACTERIZE IT AS
THE MOST RECKLESS PRESIDENCY AND
DANGEROUS PRESIDENCY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
>> Juan: LET ME SAY THIS IS
THE SAME GUY WHO WAS INSULTING
KIM JONG UN WHO WE ALL THINK IS
ON EDGE ANYWAY.
HE CALLS THEM ROCKET MAN.
THEN HE SAYS YOU KNOW WHAT, MY
BUTTON IS BIGGER THAN YOUR
BUTTON.
TALK ABOUT INFANTILE.
TALK ABOUT MAKING THE WHOLE
WORLD --
>> Greg: THAT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM FLAW.
>> Juan: PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, IS ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HIS POWER?
>> Greg: YOU WOULDN'T HAVE LET
THIS HAPPEN.
>> Juan: NO, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A FAR MORE SERIOUS THREAT
THAN SOME GOVERNMENT GUY MAKING
A MISTAKE.
>> Greg: IT IS THE LARGEST
A BIG DEAL?
>> Juan: I DIDN'T SAY IT
WASN'T A BIG DEAL.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THE BIGGER
DEAL IF IT NORTH KOREA ACTUALLY
FIRES A NUCLEAR WEAPON AT HAWAII
>> Greg: WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THAT.
YOU ARE TRYING TO CREATE A
DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON THIS.
CAREFUL TO SAY IT WAS THE STATE.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT THE STATE.
YOU HEARD FROM CHRISTIAN NIELSEN
YESTERDAY ON FOX NEWS SUNDAY.
HE SAID IT WAS AN UNFORTUNATE
THAT'S ALL IT WAS.
>> Jesse: I FEEL MORE SAFE
UNDER COMMANDER IN CHIEF TRUMP
THEN I WOULD UNDER
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF OBAMA.
>> Juan: WHY IS THAT?
>> Jesse: ISN'T THAT CLEAR?
I DON'T THINK PRESIDENT OBAMA
DID ANYTHING.
HE MADE IT WORSE.
ON THE CELEBRITY THING, THEY
BLAME TRUMP FOR SOMEONE PUSHING
THE WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA.
JENNIFER LAWRENCE PLANES TRUMP
FOR THE HURRICANE BECAUSE GOD
WAS MAD AT HIS ELECTION.
LENA DUNHAM BLAMED TRUMP FOR HER
TRUMP'S FAULT.
>> Greg: YOGURT FOR BRAINS
JAMIE LEE CURTIS SAID THE HAWAII
MISSILE SCARE IS ON YOU,
MR. TRUMP.
YOU.
THE REAL FEAR THAT MOTHERS AND
THIS IS NO HELP FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE PANICKING AT THAT TIME.
PUTTING IT ON TRUMP.
YOU KNOW THIS IS?
SELF-SERVING PEACOCK PREENING.
LOOK AT ME.
HELP.
USING ALL CAPS AND YOUR 50.
>> Greg: SHE HAS OTHER ISSUES
WITH THE FILMING OF "TRUE LIES."